hello Greg it's me
how are you doing this is Brianne
Brianne Chandler yeah
Brianne is Miss movies everywhere
YouTube Twitter Instagram she's also uh
she recently won a singles match in the
movie trivia shmatte oh whoa oh yeah
she's badass she brought some cool
outfits on there hey Brianne hey Greg
have you heard of this movie called
hounds of love no but man is it having
anything to do with the house it looks
like it might be a British movie or
something I am a lot of people were
requesting this he says Stephen Curry
Emma booth and Ashley Cummings I don't
know if I know any of those names those
are all some like British people but
when we see this maybe I'll be like oh
yeah I know her maybe it's a scary
trailer true crime you know rightly the
team parents savvy and a bloke can he's
got your ticket to Adelaide
we see kids run off like this every day
sex workers now definitely she's pretty
[Music]
even a minute I was like nope too long
for me it sounds like it's about a
couple who kidnaps a girl and they do
sexual things to her let's just make
sure we got the right description hey
you have MD but here Vickie Maloney is
randomly abducted from a suburban street
by a disturbed couple yes as she
observes the dynamic turn her captor she
quickly realises you spell realizes it
is how does he know mr. I would watch
between them if she is Sisera that's a
fascinating plot right there that's
something you watch I'm not going to
watch this oh I'm very like that trailer
I definitely had chills at one point
yeah this is something I feel like I
shouldn't be watching this when they
were talking in the meeting about like
you're gonna write this letter that you
met someone or whatever it reminds me of
the Fritzl case out of Austria remember
that guy in like Ohio that had his three
girls anything was Ohio and then that
one man like found them and had been
missing for a long time I've heard many
stories like that I haven't heard this
recent and they were gone for years like
fellowship were they alive thing they
were alive okay one of them had a kid
with him they were abducted by him room
is based off of the Fritzl case the man
imprisoned his own daughter for 30 years
I want to say I want to say 30 years I
believe had seven children with her all
under his house like he had this area
under his house he like locked her in
there the mom thought that she like left
that she wrote a lip like he had her
write a letter I was like I've joined
this cults and I'm leaving this baby
with you to care for it's the most
disturbing case that I have ever read
about in my life yeah it was something
like six
and children none of them ever saw the
light of day the daughter they convinced
him that the daughter was going to die
and that's why they needed to get out
from below and I don't maybe it wasn't
30 years maybe it was 19 years or
something it was a long time oh that's
that's not too bad but basically he
could she convinced him that this girl
needs to leave because she needs to get
to a hospital right and that was the
first time I did hear this one yeah yeah
I did
that's how they yeah I remember that now
I remember that pop this makes me think
of that story and I'm like I cannot like
lose through all those emotions just
reading that story I've never had more
emotions about like something that's
happened to my life well this is it as
bad as that is still pretty horrible
horrible I mean this is fascinating to
me when I was younger like right when
Netflix was launching their streaming
there was a series on there called
serial killer couples or something okay
and every every episode was like a
documentary an hour-long documentary
about couples yeah couples that were
killers and I was fascinated with it I
watched like many episodes and I'm kind
of drawn to stories about serial killers
recap
capture not a big fan of like stories
that involve you know molestation or
rape um not but when it comes to like
killers people who kill I get into that
do you listen to my favorite murder
podcast no I've heard its various I mean
they talk about real life real killers
but they they're two comedians so they
go about talking about it in such an
interesting informal way here to me
I think the acting looks dynamite and I
think the acting looks incredibly superb
I just think it's a solid type of plot I
mean this wasn't supposed to be like a
90 minute a hundred minute movie the the
concept of a girl who's a woman who's
been kidnapped and the only way to
survive this or get out of this is to
drive a wedge in between her two captors
is is such a fascinating I feel like
this could sum
play out kind of like a play if it's
primarily in the home we don't see too
many other locations at the police
station he's there talking about
possibly burying her in the woods
other than that though I feel like most
of this is probably gonna take place in
the home and with a lot of solid
dialogue and I'm also drawn to movies
where characters like they don't
necessarily arc well that's it is an art
but it's more like a deterioration
where they just get worse and worse the
human beings right yeah yeah they become
they evolve into something worse and a
lot of these serial killer couple
stories it's usually a wife or the
girlfriend who's the first one to start
like snapping out of it or breaking or
trying to get out of it in some way and
it looks like that's the path that it's
going down here the emotions that I felt
inside my body for one minute like to go
from zero to sixty now maybe I did maybe
didn't see that on the outside but I was
like oh no this looks very disturbing
I'm kind of glad this wasn't a red band
trailer because I can write I can only
imagine like what graphic violence or
sexual misconduct is gonna take place in
this film this doesn't look like the
kind of movie that's gonna shy away from
things like that this looks like a very
uncomfortable unsettling experience it's
one of those movies where you get into a
conversation with someone where they're
like why would you want to put yourself
through that and I'm there going I don't
know I find it entertaining for some
freaks in so I'm gonna go watch it I
want to see if this is already rated oh
the parents guy let's go over the
parents you've never done the parents
guy okay hey guys here's what the
parents guy is on IMDB when you're a
parent sometimes you need to know what
are the things that are gonna be showing
up in this movie you might want not want
to show your children first of all
probably not good is gonna tell you all
the things you're gonna see oh and this
is it right here
normally well go through like
specifically you're going to see a rape
scene you're gonna see like and it'll be
very specific about that scene sex
annuity violence ignore profanity
alcohol drugs smoking frightening
intense scenes this sounds like a really
delightful
family film another tip if you want to
kind of spoil it for yourself which
sometimes I do I look at the keywords on
a movie as well and - then I know like
Oh someone's gonna be eating a finger in
this film and also I'm really drawn to
the weight of the film shot - it's shot
really neatly like all the framing of it
it looks the cinematography looks
absolutely excellent like creepy but
beautiful like this shot that we're
looking at it's like when you pull it up
it's like the shot that you see that's
like click play for trailers
yeah I've been that shot with like the
wallpapering and her against kind of
it's a good representation of what the
film is actually right there I'm really
interested to see how all the things
play and how the how the main characters
are all playing their cards throughout I
think I'm gonna watch this movie can we
check out Ben young who's the director
and the writer let's see what else he's
done if this is his first film it is his
first film all right
he's worked on the shows trapped
castaway and prank Patrol solid solid
prank Patrol it looks amazing
free quit your old show is such like a
comedy Franco and then you got this like
gritty realistic violins of love movies
all right well yeah hey thanks for
recommending that our way subscribe to
the real rejects click the notification
Bell yay bran Chandler miss movies on
the Internet
that's YouTube Instagram Twitter go
check her out everywhere and hey we
recently launched the patreon account we
got a lot of fun things on there that
you guys would really love we're doing
more we're gonna have exclusive video
content down there I'm gonna make a
little announcement soon but there's
gonna be a lot of exclusive videos on
there so wait get a wink wink wink so I
don't pick up girl nut bars
hey hey babe
yeah